oui on sera qui en fait des péripéties
guerrière qui lui font actuellement un
statut indices
la jordanie est un pays de 97 milles 740
km carrés dont 755 km carrés de mer
morte et il est tendu indéterminé de
vallonnements désertique en divisant le
pays en deux le jour dans l'ue a donné
son nom à l'ouest la samarie
fourmillante de souvenirs biblique à
l'est les neuf dixièmes du territoire
des d'immenses richesses archéologiques
amman la capitale est bâti sur cette
colline et un certain nombre
d'hypothèques anglo saxon des outils de
silex établissent la présence en ce lieu
d'un homme préhistorique
à moins qu'une annonce la venue d'un
homme post atomique
tous les conquérants du monde antique
sont passés par là avec leurs soldats
leurs chars et leurs dieuze et leurs
démons 30 ans avant jésus-christ hérode
le grand prix la ville est bâti dessus
si j'ose dire un énorme temple des
reculs destiné à placer son gouvernement
sous le patronage définitive de la force
le temple a subsisté et rendent non
depuis beaucoup de sable couler dans les
ca vu le christianisme byzantin puis
l'islam sont venus et d'autre et
l'angleterre enfin avec ses comptoirs
ses cannes de golf et ses experts en
gisements pétrolifères
pétrus non petroleum pendant quelques
temps les jordaniens purent se féliciter
d'avoir une gouvernante anglaise leur
appris beaucoup de choses et notamment
le bon usage de la cavalerie
voyez plutôt l'adresse de ses lanciers
par nature
à
j'ai fait entre romain et sans doute le
monument le plus imposant d'amman il a
été taillé dans la courbe d'une colline
et il convient simili place d'où l'on
peut voir commodément sans rien perdre
des spectacles aussi rares que la
musique écossaise légion arabe jouant de
la cornemuse en souvenir de sa majesté
mais le personnage principal de ce côté
de la méditerranée
c'est le grand marchand de sable
orientale qui vient périodiquement
endormir les civilisations qui n'ont pas
toujours su ce qu'il paraît qu'elle
était mortel
c'est lui qui a enseveli jerash dans les
ruines de ces maisons de son forum de
son temple et artemis de son arc de
triomphe à la gloire des dryats et de
son amphithéâtre
depuis des siècles les arabes disent
d'un paysage ravagé qu'il est désolé
comme les ruines de jerash
e
non
jerash est à inscrire à l'actif du
marchand de sable orientale tout comme
le fantôme de l'admirable petra à trois
heures de voiture dahmane et qui vit à
l'issue d'un défilé six lieux la survie
rêveuse des cités abandonnées au
souvenir de leur beauté
oh
e
l'histoire ici s'est arrêté un moment
elle est morte quelque part entre le
trésor du pharaon le théâtre creusés
dans les falaises et qui attend une
reprise improbable de la tragédie
humaine
petra cela empire du silence
et des ombres qui s'allonge lentement
dans une étrange lumière de veilleuses
rose petra la rose et moore cch
un cabas sur la belle rouge par contre
n'est pas encore sortie de l'histoire
c'est une ville commerciale un port une
plage un centre touristique un club
nautique
des plans ont été établis pour élargir
la ville moderniser son équipement des
architectes proposent et billy tel
dispose un cabas a été un endroit
élégant depuis quelques temps c'est un
endroit très fermé
bon
entre petra et aqaba et pourquoi ne
reviendrions nous pas en arrière dans un
pays où le passé attend tranquillement
l'avenir au détour de tous les chemins
le wa dirhams surnommée la vallée de la
lune fournit aux imagination poétique un
matériel impressionnant
c'est ici que lawrence d'arabie avait
établi ses quartiers
c'est ici dit on qu'il a écrit quelques
pages des sept piliers de la sagesse
c'est aussi dans cette vallée
fantastique que le voyageur a le plus de
chance de rencontrer le fameux marchand
de sable orientale dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure
celui qui tire son linceul de poussière
sur les villes perdues celui qui avec
l'aide du vent efface les traces de
l'homme sur la terre
celui qui glisse un nouveau tapis de
sable sous les pas des pas trop il est
des bergers qui sans trop le savoir
pete leur tante de poils de chèvre sur
les vestiges de quelques empire déglutit
jusqu'au troisième sous-sol et foule de
leurs pas nonchalant l'un des plus beaux
cimetière de civilisations du monde
à
matthew wilson muna lee
m
et